if you guys had to audition for The
Voice what would you sing Lick It Up by
KISS
despite our bickering and my domination
of him on TV this guy is actually my
good friend he sold millions of Records
charted 28 whatever number one singles
please welcome my friend Blake Shelton
so how are things of the voice I know
you miss me there is one person we've
found who can talk as much as you and
that's Camila although unlike you when
she talks she makes sense
do you remember your first ever
performance my mom would enter me into
pageants like literally pageants because
so I could sing in the talent portion
yeah did your evening wear end up
helping you win though you just wanna
just want to see the pictures you want
you want some pictures to have in your
house I remember the first time I went
to Oklahoma with my family we are like
from Anaheim we've never seen even trees
before so we were like wow this is like
crazy and we're like driving in Lake's
in his truck and there's a tree that had
like been blown down on the road and
like gets out and he's like all right
and he gets in the back of the truck he
has like chainsaw a big chain and he
pulled it out he wrapped it around the
tree and like pulled like my whole
family's like oh my God
it was like
I've noticed over the years that you
play a lot of games even outside of the
show I didn't you're you're a gamer
this is a gift that represents
every person who has beaten you on your
show yes it's called the wall of
Champions it's Arnold Schwarzenegger
yeah this piece of crap show
what are the names
I did what she was getting at what do
you think
I do remember that you let us drink last
time we were on this show
would you like a drink yes I will say
most times drinking with you it doesn't
end well for me but it's fine did you
choose Tishomingo I can't believe you
did a shot of vodka I can already tell
you're starting to act weird let's go
ahead and smell the first one okay what
are you smelling Blake wine what do you
mean
and then I want you to swirl it around
your palate for about five or six
seconds and expose all your taste buds
to it
this is actually the first thing I've
ever done on this show that's worth the
crap
I had never really gotten sick from
drinking boy and it was Blake's fault
Blake kept handing me things like Irish
car bombs I'm like dude what it's not
gonna go well they say you were dropped
in the wilderness and you can only pick
one of us
to be with you to help you get through
the Wilderness I mean I think they're
going to be boring and they're going to
take each other but like what are you
what who would you pick I picked Blake I
would kill him and take the vodka in his
back pocket
because I got news for you
you see his Starbucks mug on The Voice
right you all see yeah it ain't coffee
you wear your jacket all the time oh my
God you know it's interesting you left
your jacket here in the Green Room
actually yeah yeah yeah you actually
neglected to even throw it away after
leaving the building oh there it is I've
been looking for this yeah so let's see
how smart Lola really is this is the
test okay she has one button with my
face on it and one button with Blake
Shelton who's your favorite Voice coach
Lola
oh is that me it was you yes
take that shot and even dogs Adore Me on
a show with Blake Shelton are you you
would oh my God actually or is he is
that would be so you would love him it's
really fun to work with people that can
put their ego aside and just have a good
time
what can I say about this guy except
that of all the coaches on The Voice
he's without a doubt the tallest
[Applause]
it's my last season on The Voice
I want you to be on my team and I hate
Kelly Clarkson
that's what it usually sounds like
[Music]
[Applause]
y'all have a great night
[Music]